individuals have to live within their
means but it seems like governments can
keep going how long can we keep this
party going
by the way governments and people are
sort of in it together so when a
government runs a deficit it's giving
money to people we as a country are are
doing that and we're printing it and
what happens mechanistically financially
is that one man's debts are another
man's assets
uh you own a bond for example and as its
return um goes down relative to
inflation and inflation pressures rise
people start to think investors start to
think um how am i doing relative to
inflation we're now at that point we're
so used to thinking that the amount of
our wealth is measured in the amount of
money we have
not the amount of buying power that we
have and so as the inflation rate starts
to rise
that causes um holders of bonds and
other assets to start to sell those
because they and holders of cash to not
want to hold those
and that not that essentially increases
the amount of the central bank has to
print of money because not only do they
have to fund the deficit but they have
to make up that funding gap and that
dynamic
is a very risky dynamic very classic